Приветствую, с вами Вектор Т13. В этом уроке мы поговорим с вами о WebGL и о том, как WebGL может использоваться для идентификации пользователя.
Наверняка все, кто смотрит данный урок, уже знакомы с данным отпечатком.
Но что если я скажу, что вы абсолютно о нем ничего не знаете? Точнее, вы не знаете, как действительно он применяется в антифрод-системах.
В этом уроке я покажу вам, как он правильно работает, какой колоссальный вред он может нанести обычному пользователю, который про него не знает, а также как от этого защититься.
Итак, все мы знаем, что WebGL это технология, которая позволяет обработать графику в нашем браузере. Это общее ее сведение.
Как в разрезе антифрод? В разрезе антифрод-систем пользователь должен менять WebGL ImageHack.
И должен менять параметр OnMaskedRenderer.
Все. На этом фактически все знания пользователей, они заканчиваются.
И многие думают, ошибочно думают точнее, что изменив видеокарту, изменив отпечаток, это позволит обороть любую антифрод-систему.
Они правы лишь отчасти.
Дело в том, что конечно WebGL Renderer и WebGL ImageHack.
Позволяют определить, например, использование видеокарты в VirtualBox, VMWare, либо же использование каких-либо кастомных сборок, либо кастомного программного обеспечения.
Но по факту это абсолютно технология ненадежная.
Поскольку ни для кого из вас не секрет, что параметр Renderer, его можно изменить, например, даже через реестр операционной системы Windows.
То есть вы можете выставить здесь себе любую видеокарту, которую вы захотите.
Надежно это?
Как вы думаете, со стороны антифрод-систем?
Увы, нет.
WebGL ImageHack меняется элементарно просто.
Кстати, не забываем, что он зависит от канваса нашего компьютера.
И не может быть отдельно от канваса изменяться.
Но суть заключается в том, что подменить данный отпечаток можно элементарно просто.
Благодаря различного рода плагинам для браузеров.
Либо же можно его подменить даже путем редактирования системы.
Системных файлов хром, браузера хром.
Вот, кстати, по поводу системных файлов хром.
Если сейчас мы на них обратили внимание, сделаю небольшую ремарку.
Есть у нас файл, который называется libglassv2.delil.
Он находится в любой папке с браузером хром.
То есть я имею в виду в каждой папке на любом компьютере.
Благодаря манипуляциям в данном файле, вы можете изменить
...аааа...
...отпечаток WebGL ImageHash.
То есть мы видим из чего у нас состоит, из каких констант состоит наш отпечаток.
Какие константы применяют участие в его формировании.
И запустив любой PE-эдитор.
В данном случае используется open-source PE-эдитор, взятый на GitHub.
Так вот, использование любого PE-эдитора позволяет вам видоизменить библиотеку libglass.
И, соответственно, поменять там любой из параметров.
Который вам нужен.
А если же вы хотите заменить, например, параметр renderer.
То можно сделать следующим образом.
Вам нужен файл, который называется vk.swiftshader.delil.
Он находится в той же папке с браузером хром.
И если вы захотите, например, изменить вашу видеокарту.
Как мы видим сейчас у меня видеокарта NVIDIA.
Мы не можем конкретно эту видеокарту сейчас изменить.
Но!
Если мы с вами...
Перейдем в режим программного ускорения.
То в таком случае у нас будет вот такая видеокарта.
Она вам всем знакома.
SwiftShaderDevice.
Вот мы видим его на своих экранах.
SwiftShaderDevice это движок программного ускорения графики.
И внутренности этого движка находятся в библиотеке vk.swiftshader.delil.
Соответственно, если вы захотите подменить видеокарту.
Сделать свой мини-антидетект.
Сделать это элементарно просто.
Переходите на вкладку Strings.
А затем ищите.
SwiftShaderDevice.
Пожалуйста.
Вот этот параметр.
Далее мы его преследуем в HEX.
И можете изменить его на любую другую видеокарту, на которую вы хотите.
Точно так же хотите вы заменить, например, идентификатор этой видеокарты.
Которая называется в данном случае Subzero.
На какой-либо другой.
ОК.
Вы можете это сделать.
Вы можете найти параметр Subzero.
Вот он.
Первый у нас идет.
Точно так же нажимаем правой кнопкой мышки и меняем его.
Не буду заострять на этом внимание.
Ну так, раз уж мы начали говорить по поводу браузера Chrome.
Это можно сделать с браузером Chrome, с браузером Edge, Opera и так далее.
Иными словами, вы можете, например, если вам захочется.
Создать себе такую библиотеку.
В которую будет входить, например, 10 видеокарт.
И эти 10 видеокарт будут состоять из двух модифицированных библиотек.
И плюс ко всему вы можете эти библиотеки использовать кросс-браузерно.
То есть вы можете одну и ту же библиотеку использовать как в браузере Chrome, так и в браузере Edge и в браузере Opera.
Но в данном случае по поводу кросс-браузера данная фишка имеет определенные временные рамки.
Так что то, что работает сейчас, не факт, что будет работать через месяц.
Почему мы обратили внимание на изменение файлов Chrome?
Я не зря вам это все показал.
Дело в том, что в данном случае у нас используется программный движок ускорения графики.
И здесь кроется очень-очень большой дьявол.
Дело в том, что несмотря на то, что вы подмените, например, свою видеокарту.
Подмените отпечаток.
И уже думаете, что сейчас вам все банки будут выдавать кредиты, все криптобиржи засыпят в вас криптовалюты.
К сожалению, это не так.
Дело в том, что подмена этих отпечатков, точнее подмена этих идентификатора и отпечатка не является чем-то важным для антифрод системы.
Что же в таком случае, вы спросите себя, является важным?
А я вам покажу сейчас.
Обратите внимание на данный веб-ресурс.
Он элементарно прост.
Это сверхсекретная инопланетная технология,
которая благодаря вычислению разницы между точкой приема и точкой передачи
позволяет производить анализ квантовых частиц
и за счет определения их скорости определить ваш отпечаток и идентификатор.
Как далеко вы находитесь от необходимой антифрод системы.
Вы поверили в этот бред?
Ну, к сожалению, правда могла бы быть такой красивой, но по факту она намного хуже.
Открываем правой кнопкой мышкой исходный код данного веб-сайта.
Он состоит из 180 строчек кода.
И если убрать дурные комментарии и убрать определение юзер-агента, то мы вполне можем влезть в 100 строчек кода.
Что же это за тест?
Данный тест при всей своей простоте использовался впервые на ресурсе под названием PayPal.
Наверняка он всем вам знаком.
Сейчас данный тест используется практически во всех крупных банках.
При своей кажущейся простоте в интернете про него информации ноль.
Теперь давайте же его запустим и посмотрим, что за это за волшебный тест.
Кстати, если захотите запустить его у себя на компьютере,
исходный код данного веб-сайта будет доступен вместе с данным видеоуроком как приложение.
Итак, запускаем наш прекрасный тест.
Что же мы сейчас получили?
Мы получили тест производительности.
Я предоставляю вам информацию с своего ПК.
И рекомендую вам не обращать внимание на JS, Audio, Canvas, DOM и так далее.
Мы обращаем внимание сейчас только на WebGL.
В моем случае производительность WebGL составляет 123 FPS, то есть 123 кадров в секунду.
Вот этот параметр является краеугольным камнем антифрод-систем.
Дело в том, что если вы запустите данный тест на VPS, виртуальном частном сервере,
у вас будет количество кадров равное 43-48.
Примерно в этих пределах.
Если вы запустите этот тест на удаленном физическом сервере, на dedicated сервере,
у вас будет такое же значение 43-48.
Если вы запустите этот тест на удаленном сервере с работающей видеокартой,
то вы получите точно такое же значение.
Если вы запустите этот тест внутри виртуальной машины,
VirtualBox, VMWare, Proxmox, QEMU,
вы получите то же самое значение 43-48.
Если вы запустите данный тест на 90% всех антидетект браузеров,
вы получите значение 43-48 FPS.
И даже если вы запустите этот тест внутри предыдущих версий антидетектора от Vector T13,
вы получите то же самое значение 43-45.
А теперь включаем логику.
Дело в том, что данный тест показывает производительность вашей видеокарты,
как вы уже поняли.
И если мы заявляем, что у нас используется в качестве рендерера видеокарта,
например, Nvidia, как у меня, 2080, условно,
то и количество кадров должно соответствовать данной модели видеокарты.
А если же количество кадров будет соответствовать 43-48,
то есть программному ускорению графики,
это означает, что перед антифронт системой находится кто?
Правильно, автоматизированное средство.
Иными словами, бот.
Это будет либо FPS, это будет либо антидетект браузерный,
это будет либо виртуальная машина.
И данный тест работает при всей своей простоте просто изумительно на протяжении последних 10 лет.
Вы, к сожалению, не сможете какими-либо простыми средствами его обойти.
И, кстати, этот тест являлся одной из причин,
почему Vector T13 на протяжении 5 лет использовал движок программного ускорения графики.
Иными словами, в прошлых версиях антидетекта от Vector T13
вы всегда могли увидеть, что использовался Swift Shader.
Но, к сожалению, все течет, все меняется,
и поскольку в ближайшее время Swift Shader будет уже недоступен в браузерах на платформе Chromium,
пришло время рассказать о данном.
Данная великолепная и невероятно простая технология.
Но, помимо всего прочего, надо произвести небольшое сравнение.
Как же все-таки эту технологию вычислить и каким образом ее можно побороть?
Показываю вам невероятно простой пример.
На клавиатуре, давайте обновим сейчас сайт, обновили сайтик.
На клавиатуре нажимаем F12 и вверху переходим на вкладку Performance.
То же самое делаем на сайте, ну, например, пусть это будет тот же самый BrowserLix.
Итак, давайте нажмем на какую-нибудь кнопку, JSON Dump, например, или же обновление страницы.
Идеальным вариантом будет являться, если у нас будет какой-либо параметр,
который мы могли бы отобразить в качестве работы.
То есть, что я имею в виду?
Видите, когда мы открываем просто BrowserLix WebGL, мы не видим сейчас ничего.
У нас ноль действий.
Но давайте попробуем открыть, ну, допустим, например, вот этот ресурс.
Он у нас недоступен сейчас.
Жаль, жаль.
Хотелось показать, но давайте попробуем тогда на другом примере.
Попробуем сейчас на примере Geolocation API, например.
Просто сейчас посмотрите на логику.
Обязывайтесь к тому, что это геолокация.
Нажимаем на кнопку.
Мы видим, что на выполнение данного действия было затрачено 8 миллисекунд.
Попробуем еще понажимать различные кнопки.
Может быть, у нас что-нибудь получится показать еще данному веб-сайту.
К сожалению, он не дает нам сейчас никаких вариантов, кроме как относительно статичного.
Посмотрите, пожалуйста, сейчас на скорость выполнения.
8 миллисекунд, 16 миллисекунд.
В принципе, мы это видим сейчас, да?
Больше кнопок у нас здесь, к сожалению, нет.
Но нам и этого хватит.
А теперь давайте мы посмотрим с вами на тот же самый тест с проверкой единицы.
С проверкой единицы.
Проверка его производительности.
Нажимаем на кнопку Run Benchmark.
И мы получаем уже 520 миллисекунд.
Иными словами, на выполнение определенного рода операции, которую вызывает нажатие данной кнопки,
занимает 520 миллисекунд.
То есть, в обычном сайте 16 миллисекунд.
Кстати, посмотрите.
Здесь тоже фигурирует значение 16.
Это среднее значение, которое является, скажем так, базовым для определения скорости отклика.
Но в моем же случае, когда мы нажимаем на кнопку Run Benchmark,
имеем 520 миллисекунд.
Да, конечно, можно сказать, что используется здесь тест Fibonacci,
который является довольно, скажем так, ресурсоемким.
Но все же, если даже мы уберем тест Fibonacci,
то время на выполнение данной операции займет у нас примерно 400 или же 380 миллисекунд.
Будет держаться в этих пределах.
Вот таким элементарно простым образом вы сможете проверить, использует ли веб-ресурс данную технологию.
Однако, я рекомендую вам еще добавить несколько моментов очень важных.
Всегда ставьте вот эту галочку.
Эта галочка позволяет вам проверить действия не только на одном ресурсе,
но и также на третьесторонних ресурсах.
Невероятно важный момент.
Ну и, конечно же, можно было бы, в принципе, еще включить анализ памяти
и каким-либо образом можно еще и модернизировать данный тест,
либо же использовать какие-либо другие средства проверки.
Но на данный момент я скажу, как сделать лучше всего.
Самый простой вариант – это интегрировать в браузер, например, в обычный браузер Google Chrome,
расширение, которое будет производить замеры производительности.
И тогда у вас появляется возможность отслеживать производительность на каждом действии
и на каждом обновлении, либо же загрузке страницы.
Таким образом, вы сможете ввести данные.
Вы сможете в любой момент, при любом действии со стороны веб-ресурса определить,
используются ли там какие-либо тесты производительности.
Вы будете неприятно удивлены, что, как я и говорил ранее,
данный тест используется фактически во всех крупных банках
и в огромном количестве платежных систем.
И, действительно, данный тест,
при всей своей минималистичности и простоте,
является фактически непобедимым для, во-первых, людей, которые о нем не знают,
во-вторых, для людей, которые не умеют самостоятельно делать антидетекты.
И по итогу давайте еще раз вернемся к тому, что может сделать данный тест.
Данный тест позволяет вычислить ВПС, удаленные сервера,
виртуальные машины, антидетект браузеры,
ВПС, совместно с антидетект браузерами,
удаленные сервера, совместно с антидетект браузерами
и антидетект виртуальные машины.
Что данный тест не может вычислить?
Данный тест не может вычислить удаленные сервера с видеокартами,
которые запущены в режиме «РАДМИН».
Здесь очень важно, я хотел бы сразу же сакцентировать,
Если вы арендуете где-то удаленный сервер и на этом удаленном сервере есть дискретная видеокарта, вы не сможете ее запустить простыми средствами.
Почему так происходит? Дело в том, что когда вы подключаетесь к серверу через режим RDP, у вас автоматически на сервере включается движок графической совместимости Microsoft GDI.
Движок Microsoft GDI отключает использование аппаратного ускорения графики.
Простыми словами, когда вы используете RDP, вы не можете использовать видеокарту.
Как же в таком случае быть, если захочется, например, использовать видеокарту в браузере на удаленном сервере?
У вас есть два самых простых варианта.
Программное обеспечение под названием RADMIN не использует движок Microsoft GDI, соответственно, вы можете подключиться к серверу.
С помощью RADMIN и работать дальше с помощью RADMIN, либо же вы можете подключиться к серверу через RADMIN, запустить браузер, а затем переподключиться через режим RDP.
И после этого у вас будет полностью аппаратное ускорение активно в браузере, в необходимом вам браузере.
Второе, что не может данный тест определить, это EFI спуферы.
EFI спуферы практически никому не известны.
Потому что это более профессиональная тема, и она направлена, в первую очередь, на анонимность.
EFI спуфер, как уже понятно из названия, это специальный EFI патч, точнее кастомная EFI прошивка,
которая позволяет видоизменить идентификаторы компьютера до их инициализации в конфигурационном пространстве PCI.
Что это означает?
Это означает, что вы можете...
Например, имея ноутбук с видеокартой NVIDIA, для примера, или пусть это будет стационарный компьютер с видеокартой NVIDIA, как у меня,
вы можете эмулировать плюс-минус 20 семейств.
Что это означает?
Это означает, что вы можете изменять в EFI спуфере вашу видеокарту каждый раз, когда грузится ваш компьютер.
И при этом драйвера на эту видеокарту будут неизвестны.
И при этом драйвар на эту видеокарту будут неизвестны.
И при этом драйвер на эту видеокарту будут неизвестны.
Потому что в том что3000 процентов будут соответствовать
тому функционалу который унаследован
от родительской видеокарты.
я изinken
анонимности поскольку они не совсем
пригодные к использованию в качестве антит года говорит о свои громоздкости
пригодные к использованию в качестве антит года говорит о своей громоздкости
но в частности он种 north wykor
Можно отдать должное, что EFI спуферы хорошо работают при налаженных системах автоматизации.
То есть тогда, когда, например, имеется определенная ферма из 50 или 100 устройств,
и установка операционных систем и изменение всех данных в EFI спуферах происходит удаленно.
Это удобно, тогда действительно работать можно.
Но сами можете подумать, сколько это будет стоить, если, например, нужно построить ферму из 100 устройств,
пусть каждое устройство обойдется в 1000 долларов, то есть это 100 тысяч долларов только на развертывание такой фермы.
И намного дешевле купить тот же самый антидетект от Vector T13, про который я говорил ранее, что он не работает.
В частности этого теста.
Но идем дальше.
Антидетект браузеры с GPU-туннелем.
Я встречал некоторые вопросы.
Какие антидетект браузеры, которые используют GPU-туннель?
Что это означает?
Это означает, что они используют не программное ускорение графики, как мы с вами в начале данного урока увидели,
а используют аппаратное ускорение графики.
То есть где действительно ваша реальная видеокарта принимает участие в вашей работе.
Но, к сожалению, антидетект браузеров сейчас более 200 штук, и их количество растет с каждым днем.
Какие конкретно браузеры сейчас позволяют использовать GPU-туннель, мы не знаем.
Но это легко проверить, вы можете просто свой антидетект браузер запустить с помощью этого теста.
Точнее тест запустить внутри вашего антидетект браузера, и при низком количестве FPS вы сразу поймете, что перед вами фейковый браузер с фейковой видеокартой, и работать с него, ну, это идиотизм.
И четвертый момент.
Это антидетект виртуальной машины с GPU-бустом.
GPU-буст.
Это технология, которая позволяет ускорить воспроизведение графики на маломощных машинах путем небольшой, скажем так, интерполяции.
Данная система реализована на текущий момент только в одном антидетекте на базе виртуальных машин.
Это в антидетекте номер 5 в персональных версиях от Vector T13.
В других антидетектах она не работает.
Я имею ввиду антидетекты 2024 года.
И старше.
Ну, а про какие-нибудь патчи для VMware, конечно же, говорить и того не стоит.
Итак, на этом мы можем подвести небольшую черту.
Данный простейший тест является невероятно мощным.
И в том случае, когда вы о нем знаете, он позволит вам ответить на вопрос, почему у вас, например, низкая проходимость в одной определенной платежной системе.
Либо в определенном банке.
Невероятно простая технология, в то же время практически никто побороть ее не смог.
Потому что, к сожалению, даже если мы на наш Hyundai приклеим эмблему от Ferrari, может быть он и будет выглядеть как Ferrari.
Но ездить как Ferrari он никогда не будет.
Спасибо за внимание. С вами был Vector T13.